uh yes you can but i'm going to
introduce you
okay uh you can see my slides right uh
make it full
yeah now it's a full screen that's
awesome okay let me
let me start the seminar
okay uh welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics as usual first of all please
mute yourself during the talk unless you
have questions
if you do have questions clarify
clarification
questions you're welcome to mute
yourself and
ask those questions otherwise please use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them
in q a session at the end second the
today's ddps seminar is open to external
audiences and therefore
no classified discussion is allowed
of course please
so watch out for that and finally the
talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our youtube channel
so that's about it now let me introduce
our speaker today
it is an honor to host professor
javier until uh who is a professor
in department of mathematical sciences
and founder and director of center for
mathematics and artificial intelligence
at george mason university
currently there are many exciting things
going on
in the center so please check that out
when you get a chance he got his phd in
applied mathematics at university of
houston
uh texas in 2009 prior to joining george
mason university he was a postdoctoral
postdoctoral researcher at rice
university
his research interests include algorithm
development
for pde constraint optimization deep
learning
artificial intelligence and dimensional
reduction
okay today javier will present
applications
of fractional operators from optimal
control to machine learning
which is a great interest to us so
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
from javier
now without further ado let me pass the
button to
javier by asking one random question
to make the stage somewhat comfortable
for both speakers and audiences today's
random question
is what is the most beautiful place you
ever s
you ever visited or seen
[Music]
i would say that the german alps
so that's the most prettiest place i've
been to oh where is it i never heard of
it
uh german alps so like in in uh south of
munich
you have uh uh alps mountains right so
that's
beautiful beautiful place indeed indeed
i totally agree with you okay it's all
yours
right there thank you uh jung soo for
for for this very
kind introduction and also um inviting
me and giving this opportunity
um so and and thanks to
to the audience also uh for for for
being part of this session
so as youngster mentioned so today i
will discuss some of our work that we've
been doing for last
i would say three three and a half years
on on on fractional operators this is
one of the
research topic in our group we
we do have several other things and i'm
happy to describe
them to you if you're interested
this work is partially supported by
national science foundation and also air
force office of scientific research and
department of navy naval postgraduate
school
so um as johnson mentioned earlier there
are there are a few things
that we are there are several
initiatives going on
under our center for mathematics and
artificial intelligence
and just to advertise couple of them i
didn't prepare any slides but i can just
mention to you guys
uh so we run a weekly colloquium we are
on a little break at the moment during
the summer
but there are a couple of couple of
activities that we have planned
uh one is a summer school on uh june
18th
on risk covers prediction optimization
and then there we are also doing
an event together with several
industries and national labs on june
25th
if you're interested in attending those
um those are just half a day events each
please let me know all right
so let's continue so i'm going to start
with some of the applications
of uh fractional order operators before
i get into
more mathematical details so why
why why do we care about these these
these operators
let me uh start by discussing the more
classical application
one is one application that many many
people care about
is the so-called image denoising problem
so the
issue is that you're given a noisy image
f and you want to do a reconstruction u
and you want to get rid of the noise um
and you do that by using the so-called
total variation vectorization so here i
wrote it formally as the
the l1 norm of the gradient of u but
this should be understood in the
so-called distribution sense
um you could if you if you for if you
are allowed to formally at least you can
write
uh the the euler lagrange equations
corresponding to this this problem
and you observe that that you get a
non-linear
partial differential equation and which
can be degenerate
still people are writing um papers in
this to solve this problem even though
model was introduced by rudi nausher and
fatami in 1992
and the issue is is this problem is
still quite challenging from a numerical
point of view
a few years ago in 2017 around yeah
three years ago three and a half years
ago
together with uh my uh collaborator
soren bartles from university of
freiburg in
in germany we replaced this total
variation
uh seminar by this object
delta s over 2 where this s will be my
fractional exponent
i will assume that s is between 0 and 1
and now let's look at this minimization
problem if i write
if i take the variation with respect to
u and i write
the euler range equation we get a linear
pde so we have replaced a highly
non-linear degenerate
model by a linear model now you may say
that
you have to solve a more challenging
problem with the fractional laplacian
but my claim is that is not so
challenging especially for this
particular application
because typically images are given on
square or rectangular type domains
so you can in fact just use the fourier
transform and
fft and ifft in matlab and do this
very very quickly just like five or six
lines of code
and that's what we did so if you start
with
a noisy image f this is the original
image i added some noise to that
if you start with noisy image like this
and if you solve this
this equation with an exponent i think
in this example was like 0.4
we get a recovery like this and the one
on the right
is the recovery using total variation
approach where we even optimize over
this
regularization parameter alpha over
there
and it takes a while actually to solve
this problem on the other hand this one
was extremely quick
like point zero one second or something
like that
so and and we can still preserve the
sharp features
so for example the caller uh is not
being smoothed out
so what is telling us that the
fractional operators are imposing
uh less uh smoothness compared to the
classical operator in fact
they are good in capturing this sharp
transition across interfaces
you still have to identify the exponent
s and regularization parameter alpha
you can do that by creating a bi-level
optimization
framework which we recently did in a in
a paper
which i forgot to mention actually
i forgot to add a reference here but
it's a paper together with the phd
student of mine
a former phd student of mine so where we
identify
this exponent s and alpha in a bi-level
optimization framework
i'm motivated by by
some some machine learning problems so
in particular residual
neural network i will not get into too
much detail
on that at the moment so and
then we were a bit more adventurous so
this is working so well
um and let's try to see if we can push
this further
so what we did was we make this
s not a constant anymore but it's a make
is a function of
x spatial variable and we allow it to
touch
extreme values of 0 and 1. so if you
have jump discontinuities you want to
set
as close to zero as possible and in away
from the jump discontinuities you want
to set it
close to one for example if you look at
such a noisy image
along the jump discontinuities you will
set it to be zero
then you're just imposing uh you're not
imposing any smoothness
you just have l2 functions and in the
flat regions
like here you set it close to one then
you are enforcing
h1 smoothness and you want to get rid of
the noise altogether
so this is a very adaptive model in some
sense
we did that we have a way to even
identify this exponent as
for this imaging application and we
we get such a recovery the one on the
right hand side so almost a perfect
recovery
and the middle one is the recovery that
you get using a total variation
approach where you notice that the the
corners are
are getting rounded a little bit and
that's an artifact
for using total variation approach it's
known in the literature
so we are seeing that the this this
approach of of fractional operators
is is working reasonably well for data
science type problems
and this work in particular is published
in siam journal of math analysis
it required developing several new
analysis tools
we have further extended this use of
non-local operators to the so-called
fractional diffusion maps
and so you're given a cloud of data and
you're trying to fit a manifold through
the data
so instead of using the the usual uh
heat kernel that that people
use in in diffusion maps we work with
this
uh non-local kernels because fractional
flashing is a non-local operator
and that allows us to in fact
see some interesting features this work
is just got accepted in applied
computational and harmonic analysis
journal
i'd be happy to discuss more details if
you're interested
so these are the applications from from
data science point of view of
of using these fractional operators or
non-local operators
now let's go to the physics so
um here uh together with a couple of
guys from sandia labs
bartman blumen wonders who works in
optimization and also chad weiss who is
geophysicist
we looked at a problem of so-called
magnetolorics
which is inferring the electrical
conductivity in the earth
from surface measurements and typically
one starts with the 3d maxwell's
equations and derive hal moles equation
and solve those those those those
equations to
to to capture the the
the behavior of this problem or to
capture physics
uh what we did was we started with 3d
massage equations and we use a different
constitutive relationship and we arrive
at the so-called fractional helmholtz
equation so if you know helmholtz
equation
instead of standard laplacian you have
this laplace into the power s
minus laplacian to the power s and then
we were wondering
if this this model really correspond to
some real geophysics
uh application and we implemented
we did the simulations and
so here i'm plotting the so-called
apparent resistivity versus frequency
uh i mean this is not so important
what's what's interesting is to look at
these curves
it's well known that for classical case
with the standard laplacian
you get a curve like this the flat curve
with the different fractional exponents
we saw these
bell-shaped curves and then we were
wondering if
if this really corresponds to a
realistic data
and we did find a realistic data so
apparently there are these
magnitude stations all over in the
united states
we look at the open source data from
this station located in the state of
kansas
and qualitatively our our numerical
results matches uh
almost perfectly with with with with the
numeric
with with with the experimental results
actually so that's an application from
from the physics
side so
i mean more recently we've looked at
more
more challenging problems so one is the
so-called fractional harmonic maps
this is a this problem is very well
known and
widely used in physics in particular in
ferromagnetism where you're trying to
minimize in the classical case you'll
minimize the dirichlet energy gradient
of u square
subject to some constraints
that you want to stay on the surface of
the sphere that is you impose the unit
length constraints
uh it's used this this idea is used in
in ferromagnetism
in in in modeling of liquid crystals in
uh in describing inextensible rods and
unshearable plates
in continued mechanics and in
quantum mechanics to to capture spin
dynamics
so what we did was we replaced the the
gradient of u square by
by fractional laplacian so we get a
different uh energy now
and it makes sense because what you're
really interested in in these problems
is capture singularity
and i will i will describe that in a
second
so one way to solve this problem and is
using the so-called gradient flow
so you look at the energy and you look
at the
the dynamics applied to that energy or
or sort of gradient descent method
and notice that this is a highly
non-linear partial differential equation
because this
lagrange multiplier lambda which
corresponds to this
equality constraint uh depends
nonlinearly on u
uh in the classical case you can show
that lambda is the gradient of
the l1 little l1 norm of gradient of u
and this is what i was saying that you
have a non-local
um so so so you this these problems have
singularity
so if you start with uh some some
boundary conditions
or in this case exterior conditions of x
or mod x
typically you're supposed to develop a
singularity in the middle of the domain
and that's what happens with the with an
exponent which is
0.4 fractional exponent 0.4 we see a
single
a point singularity so this is known as
the point defect
if you take smaller values of s then you
see some
more non-local defect where
singularities
are more dispersed and it turned out if
you do
if you refine your finite element mesh
sufficiently enough
this this will actually disappear and it
will uh
converge to to a point as well
um at least that's that's what it seems
to be
happening when we when we refine the
mesh
but the point is in the classical model
you have a laplacian here
and you are you are enforcing um
h1 regularity on solutions but you still
want to capture
these defects which can be challenging
especially the defects
which course which are the so-called
line defects
but this fractional model you are
enforcing less smoothness so they are
more tailored to capture
such singularities compared to the
classical models
a direct application of of of
uh of this model is is this quantum spin
chains
and in fact you start with your uh your
hamiltonian in in in in in uh
in a quantum system and then if you
write a
continuum limit you you do arrive at
this uh this this fractional
differential equation it's a non-linear
equation
um the discrete model was was derived by
these guys uh halden and shastri
in in their 88 paper and it's it's used
quite a lot
in in practice and it turned out that
this model also falls in the category of
the theory that we developed for the
previous problem
and this is the paper that we recently
[Music]
submitted so i will i will not
bore you further with with more
experiments here i just wanted to say
that we have applications of these
these operators this fraction laplacian
for example that's the one i have
discussed so far
with the constant exponent or a variable
exponent it has applications in data
science also in physics we saw from
physics point of view applications in
in geophysics and now i have shown you
some applications related to
quantum spin chains and and also
fractional harmonic maps
so now let's try to define this operator
how do you
how do you def how do you define a
fractional application
uh one way to define is is relatively
straightforward you look at the eigen
functions and eigen values
for standard laplacian with zero
boundary conditions
and then as we do typically in finite
dimensions if you are trying to compute
the powers of a positive definite matrix
you compute the eigen decomposition and
you raise the eigenvalues to that power
and that's what we do to define the
fractional laplacian you just raise the
eigenvalues to the power
s that's one way to define
this is what i'm going to call the
dirichlet fraction laplacian or the
spectral fractional application
the other definition the so-called
integral fraction laplacian
where if you want to evaluate this
object applied to you at a point
x you need to integrate uh the function
over the entire
rn and
and this clearly shows that this is a
non-local operator it's not a local
operator
as you have for the fractional appliance
as you have for the standard laplacian
where
you're computing derivatives at points
but here you need to have information
about the function
everywhere if you want to solve your
problem for instance
if i replace this rn by omega we get a
different definition so called regional
fraction laplacian but let's
not worry about that too much for a
moment
so the simplest problem that corresponds
to this this fractional pde is is
is your classical ratio problem so if we
let's consider the classical dirichlet
problem with the standard laplacian
we can impose boundary conditions on the
boundary of the domain
right and if i try to do the same thing
with fractional laplacian
we notice that this problem is not well
posed anymore because
this operator at least this integral
fractional application require you to
have information about the functions in
the exterior
so so the value well post problem is you
impose the condition u equals to g in
the exterior of the domain in rn minus
omega not just on the boundary of the
domain
this might look strange at first but
this will allow
give me gives me more flexibility and i
will come back to this point
later on in the talk
next if you want to solve this problem
we need to have integration by parts
formula so we need the notion of
normal derivative and you can define
an another integral operator which uh
converge to your classical normal
derivative
if you take the limit from the left s
going to one minus
and once you have this you can define uh
integration by parts formula so the
classical integration by part formula
that we learn
in in school is um you have grad grad
that's your bilinear form uh plus v is
the test function
times laplacian u and v times the normal
derivative of u
on the boundary and you have an
analogous result in the fractional case
as well you have a bilinear form
and then you have this term which
corresponds to this term and then you
have
[Music]
a term in the exterior which is contains
this non-local normal derivative
so now we have everything that we need
to solve these problems
so one thing we already notice is that
these operators are non-local because
they are defined in this integral sense
the other challenge is that
these problems are inherently known
smooth and that's why they work
in so well in this application that i
showed you at the beginning in in
geophysics or
or in imaging where you have jump
discontinuities
and here is an example so we consider
the simplest
problem uh just the dirichlet problem
take omega to be smooth let's say take a
unit ball
right hand side is just 1 and g is 0
then we can write an explicit solution
to this problem as given here
and in the classical dirichlet problem
if your data if your domain is smooth
and right hand side is smooth the
solutions are smooth
and we notice that in this case this is
not
not true anymore so these operators
have inherent a non-smoothness and
that's what make it
very challenging for them to analyze
both at the theoretical level and also
at the numerical another challenge at
the numerical level is
you have to discretize these integral
operators and you have to deal with
dense
numerical linear algebra
so i give a quick overview on the
implementation aspects of this
integral operators i will not get into
too much detail but just flash this
slide in case you are interested in in
the references
so once you have if you have periodic
boundary conditions then you can use
um just the fourier approach like the
one from our paper or this paper of
uh ainsworth and and mouth
if you use this dirichlet fractional
laplacian or the specular fractional
application that i introduced earlier
you can this works in arbitrary domains
and you can impose boundary conditions
also
in an appropriate way um there
there there are several options um
one is the social extension approach uh
i will not get into too much detail but
the idea is that
you turn your known local problem into a
local problem
at the expense of adding one more uh
dimension
and um and and and and this can work in
2d and 3d as well
so it's a very nice method actually
the other approach is using the so
called kato formula if you use the
function on calculus
then you can actually arrive at
arrive at a representation of the
inverse of fractional laplacian which
can be implemented
very easily just by solving the standard
poisson
equations if you are interested in
implementing this you can download the
code
from my website the other approach is
you compute the eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions for standard laplacian
but we know that that can be challenging
in arbitrary domains and it's not clear
how many
eigenfunctions you need to compute so i
won't
recommend that in general for the
integral fraction laplacian there are a
few approaches uh one is this
fan based approach originally by uh
acosta
and juan pablo over the guy um
and this this works quite well actually
and they have developed they've done a
remarkable job
uh in analyzing this as well uh the
implementation is largely motivated by
boundary element method
uh but so far it's it's limited to two
dimensions
and there is another approach by by
bonito and
and and this texas a m group where which
is motivated by
this cato formula that i mentioned
earlier um i'll not get into
more details we have recently developed
a spectral approach
which works in arbitrary dimensions and
for arbitrary domains
and the eva operator evaluation is like
n log n
and you can solve a problem with 10 to
the seven unknowns
and mind you this is a dense problem
fully dense no talk about spar system in
in 15 minutes
uh you assemble you you
you evalu you um you you can
easily apply using this this this
approach
the operator to a vector and then you
can use cg or
or or something like that to solve the
problem that's that's what um
that's that's what we did
so just to illustrate an an example here
you are given
a problem with the right-hand side one
in a unit ball
uh this was the problem that i mentioned
earlier where we where we know the exact
solution
and you can solve the problem in in in
2d
or or or in 3d and we know that
explicit solution in this case so it
works out
very well on the left side we see the
exact solution
on the right hand side is the
application of the operator onto the
discrete solution and we should get one
as is expected
so these were some some implementation
aspects so
so so far what we have discussed is i
started with several applications of
uh fractional operators and then
we we discussed how do you define these
operators
and uh and and i give a quick uh
quick overview on how to implement this
so what are the
approaches that are that that are
available to you
um we are quite interested in optimal
control problems or pd construction
automation problems in our group
and so
what is the pedigree optimization
problem you are like one
programmable typical example is you're
trying to match
uh some data let's say u sub d um
with u which solves like in this case an
a semi linear
uh pde let's say where where there is a
no linearity coming in pde
because of f and you're trying to
achieve your goal by with the help of
an unknown control variable c
so this is so your optimization
variables are u and z
and it's it turned out it's not
quite straightforward to use the
classical techniques to solve these
problems
um i will only say that for the moment
and i also want to emphasize that the
control here is on the right hand side
if you want to know more details on this
problem i recommend
these these two papers
now comes the
the so-called new notion of control for
for
so classically if you're trying to solve
let's say a diffusion equation in a
domain
typically the control is either inside
the domain or on the boundary of the
domain
now but with these fractional operators
since
uh as i mentioned at the beginning of
beginning of the talk that you need to
have information about the function
everywhere
so this um
allows actually this provides you
flexibility to to introduce
a new notion of control and that's what
we did
where you can have a control not only on
the boundary or inside but you can have
a control
far away so here you can do
a control from far away and that's what
we call the exterior control so this is
a new notion of control that we were
able to introduce
by using uh these these operators
there are a lot of technicalities
involved which you can find in
in these publications so so far these
problems that we
that i just discussed this control
problems the control is either
um in either inside the domain or in the
exterior which is this
new notion of control that we introduced
uh but in in in reality you also have
a different class of problems where the
con where you you may have
some bounce on on the solution to the
pde which is what we call the state
constraint problems
and these problems are very very
delicate uh one challenge is that
if you if you look at such a prop such a
constraint
then then your adjoint equation has
measure on the right hand side so you
need to
analyze problems with with with measures
on the right hand side
it becomes quite challenging to design
not only analysis from the analysis
point of view but also it becomes
challenging to design algorithms to
solve these type of problems
so we have looked at that and we have an
algorithm based on
a moto issue regularization in in
in recent couple of papers that that you
can find here
and all the examples that i showed you
so far uh
we assumed that the fractional exponent
was given
to to us right so
but that's not the case in reality so if
we don't know what this fractional
exponent is
so you could model this as a random
variable
and that leads to a random variable
objective function
j which you can scalarize let's say by
using this
this operator r it could be the expected
value
but we look at a more general
formulation of the so-called risk
hours measure one example is mean plus
semi deviation
so you're you have a mean and you're
trying to minimize the deviations above
the mean value
you have a max operator if i remove max
and remove this zero
then you just get the usual
deviation that that you look at but here
we are looking at the semi deviation
and the challenge is that these type of
problems
as you can see the objective function is
naturally non-smooth in general
so it's not so obvious to design or
optimization algorithms to solve this
type of problems
for for fractional operators and the key
challenge was
that you're trying to solve this problem
and your function space is
uh hs is not h1 sub loop space
and now your function space has
randomness itself
in the definition of your function space
so how do you how do you analyze this
problem
and how do you design algorithms for
that uh this is a work that
just appeared in sam journal of math
control and optimization together with
drew curry from senior national lab and
a former postdoc of mine johannes
fefferer who is now at uh tue munich
so in in this direction uh not quite
related
to to what i just talked about we have
we started a project
together with my collaborator uh reiner
leonard actually last year
after uh the shutdown in march
so um so my wife she's
she's a nurse in icu and i learned from
her
that they were having hard time creating
negative pressure flows
in their hospital um so i i spoke with
reynold and then
we we came up with some
some some simulations in in hospital
rooms and also
um this this this further led to
simulations
in in a classroom at our university for
example
uh we have recently done uh airflow
simulations in
in in aeroplanes as well and and and you
can see the effect actually
so here what's going on is a student uh
sneezed in the middle of the classroom
and uh he or she was not wearing a mask
windows were closed and after after
like 2 minutes 120 seconds so the
particles
are everywhere in the room so these are
the
these particles could potentially
contain covalent
in the second image the student was
wearing a mask
and you see the effect actually that
there are only a few particles
in the third the student was not wearing
a mask but the windows were open
and you see there are only fewer
particles and in the last image
the student was wearing a mask and the
windows were open
and you see there are only a few
particles so it really has an effect
um so this this this work
uh and also the
[Music]
some of the other stuff that we have
done recently is
is is done by combining fluid dynamics
equations with
with particle models and also combining
with computational crowd dynamics
because we also allow people to move
uh as well has appeared in uh
in in new york times couple of times and
also appeared on on on
nbc we worked closely with department of
justice as well
uh in in in maryland in new york
southern district and new york eastern
district
and have uh helped them redesign
courtrooms um
so in in in us it turned out there are
there are rules
that that witness cannot wear
mask so we want and you want to protect
the jury
right so
and how how am i connecting it to the
previous problem that these problems
that that we have looked at
they contain lot of uncertainties so
they have pds and under uncertainty and
uh
i i include this slide just to to make
people aware that there are a lot of
interesting questions out there when it
comes to optimization problems
uh with pdes that contain uncertainty
it's not quite related to the subject
that i'm discussing today
okay so we from coming back to the
fractional uh
operators we looked at some other um
things in this direction as well we
designed multi-grid algorithms to solve
uh this type of hormonal control
problems
um we looked at more sophisticated pdes
let's say with
with with peel uplash and how do you uh
analyze those problems and design
algorithms to solve them
we've we've also looked at the so-called
uh
variation inequalities so if you know
your classical obstacle problem that's
your typical variational inequality
where um where you have uh let's say you
don't want your solution to
to to cross a certain threshold
but the quasi-variation inequality is
more challenging because your obstacle
can change uh with solution as well
we have some some recent results in this
direction in particular
a new paper in science math analysis
we also develop some radius basis
approaches to solve these pds that i
mentioned earlier
more efficiently
okay so i mean at the beginning of the
talk
i mentioned uh
this minimization problem which was the
image denoising problem
but here i am looking at a more more
generic problem
where where i've introduced this
operator k in case of tomographic
tomographic reconstruction for instance
this k could be
uh radon transform
and and here the goal is to identify the
exponent
s and and regularization parameter alpha
and we did that together with with uh
with wendy d
from argon national lab and and my
former student radna khatri
this work is published in inverse
problems
and we design and so basically a
bi-level optimization
uh sort of neural network to to solve
this problem
[Music]
unfortunately given the time constraint
i'm going to skip this part and
and get get to the next next next part
of the talk
which is related to deep neural networks
and
relations to these fractional operators
and and it's basically a new new type of
fractional operator
so i know some of you many of you guys
are interested in these type problems i
know yongsu is interested in this
problem in particular
so you are given a forward problem let's
say a parameterized pde
where c is your parameter
for the for simplicity let's consider f
discrete and non-linear
parameterized pde operator c is
the parameter and you
and let's say you are interested in this
parameter to solution map so you want to
solve this problem over and over for
different parameters
and we know that it can be quite
challenging especially if you have to
solve this many many times
um and if you are working with the with
the finite element space which is
large so how do you proceed
you want to generate a surrogate right
one
one approach is use reduce basis method
or use pod approach or use the screen
empirical interpolation method
uh but then there are other approaches
like
pins for example uh
or or or there are other other type of
approaches like
um which which are more popular in in in
classification rather than than pde is
for instance
residual neural network or we introdu we
have introduced this so-called
fractional deep neural network which i
will describe shortly
so the goal here is to to extend this
work that we did earlier
and apply it apply and solve this type
of
pde is efficiently so what is this
fractional
uh deep neural network
so let's go back to the basics so you
have
you you want to study this map from
parameter to the pde solution
so what do you need to have a supervised
learning framework
you need a set of parameters let's say
c12c
ns and corresponding solution vectors
you need this data anyways if you want
to do pod for instance as well
or what i call proper orthogonal
decomposition
now yeah what is the idea the idea is
you you create a residual neural network
as written here
you have l number of layers and you use
this fl basic you use the composition of
all these
functions to to come up with a surrogate
which you call u hat c
so if you can if you can find this
representation
then you don't need to go back and solve
any pde anymore right
so you can just evaluate this u hat for
any parameter
c and you're done no more pde evaluation
needed so you really replace the pde
by this surrogate
there are a couple of questions how good
is this u hat
approximate you we do have partial
partial results
in in our paper uh which are based on
this paper of seagull
and jin chow shu from penn state
and the next so so this is an
approximation theory question
so you can ask similar question when
you're doing the finite element analysis
before solving the problem the next
question is how do you determine
uh this parameter weights and biases
one way to do this is you use
optimization as people typically do
so you solve a minimization problem
subject to constraint so it's a
constraint optimization problem
i consider this as as an ode constraint
optimization problem and why is that
because if you go back and you look at
this middle equation
this is nothing but your
forward dollar discretization of an ode
right
as written here
uh in in our work what we did was so and
and and we noticed that here right so
one layer is connected to the next
and the information is propagating um as
as as you expect with with the four four
dollar discretization of an ode
so what we did was we replaced this this
standard time derivative
by the so-called fractional time
derivative
and this is another known local operator
because if you want to evaluate this at
a point t
you need to have information about the
function from
zero to the current time so all you need
to go back
all the way so you keeping track of the
entire history
and this leads to a different type of
network which we call the fractional
deep neural network which has this
inbuilt history
so here we're replacing this ode by the
fractional ode
right and then we are discretizing it to
come up with a new network for
classification problems
we've applied this uh to to
to several sets of data you can find it
in in in this paper
and uh for for um
yeah for for the bayesian inverse
problems which i'm just going to
describe
shortly this is a recent work together
with howard allman
and uh from from us to maryland college
park
and uh my postdoc akum and my former
student uh deepanshu verma
so in the first exam example we are
trying to infer
two parameters uh c1 and c2
they're entering in the pde in a
non-linear fashion
and we here we are seeing the
l infinity error when we are doing the
training of our network when we are
using bfgs to do the training of the
network
i'm talking about the fractional uh deep
neural network that i just described
and here are the number of bfjs
iterations we notice that
after a few few 100 iterations
the error and this is this is
generalization error
which is computed on the data that
network has not seen before
after a while this error does not
change much actually so there's no point
in
in overtraining your network
but in terms of cpu time actually we see
a significant gain
so if your full model is taking like 40
minutes
a fractional dnn is taking two minutes
to
to to find these these these parameters
and this includes the training time as
well so this is not just the
online time this is offline time as well
the second example is a bit more
challenging
uh it was taken from this paper of
jeremy lan
patrick farrell and and andy stewart
and here we don't know the distribution
of
of of this coefficient
but we only have certain boundary
measurements as shown by these
circles and again with the
the gain that we see is is quite
significant from 3 hours to
18 minutes so
if you ask me if we have complete theory
for this uh we don't i don't think
anybody does but i think
these results are somewhat encouraging
so in the last part of the talk uh our
last
three four minutes i want to show you
another application
of of uh of of this this this deep
neural network
uh networks that we have developed to
the so-called chemical reacting flows
so this is a quite a challenging problem
i know many people care about this
um and this is a joint work with uh with
my colleague reiner leonard uh and fumia
takahashi
from applied simulation inc it's a
small company in in small defense
contractor in in washington this area
and a post doc thomas brown and uh and
uh
phd student panchorma who just graduated
so here uh we are if you try to let's
say do
capture the ethanol combustion so you
need to
solve set of stiff odes um
and then you need to solve fluid
dynamics equations
but it turned out that the solver is
taking 99
99 percent of solar's time is spent on
solving these uh stiff odes
so the idea is to try to replace uh
chemical reaction packages like camkin
by deep neural networks
and i mean the results that we got were
were somewhat mixed and you can see more
details in this paper which is an
archive which actually just got accepted
but let me show you a couple of examples
so in this first example we have 13
reactions in total
we did training on five reactions and
then we did testing on eight reactions
and we looked at different species plus
temperature and then um
we basically look our our network is
learning the solution at the next time
step
and then we do time marching using uh
our our
network and the results that we get
are are reasonable right so if you have
um so blue is that the actual actual
curve that you want to get and dotted
curve is what you get if you use this
dnn approach
and it's very easy to miss this this
transition it's actually
not so easy problem for for deep neural
networks
and apparently this this resonance that
i described
can do a reasonable job and
again the challenge is that you see the
the scale of
the the time scale is is is so small so
there is it's like nothing happening
nothing happening then all of a sudden
something happens and then nothing
happens
um and even sometimes the magnitude of
the solution can be pretty small as well
so this is a promising research
direction and there are there are
several things happening in this
in in in in this direction this work is
uh supported by
a dtra i think i don't think i don't
think i mentioned that
anyways i think i've um exhausted all my
time
so i will summarize i started with
several applications
of fractional operators in in imaging
in geophysics in in fractional diffusion
maps
some were data science related problems
and some were
physics-related problems we i quickly
mentioned some of our work on
on optimal control of these pdes in
particular semi-linear problems
we've done some work on quasi-linear
problems and i have looked at also state
constraint problems
in case the fractional exponent is not
known you could model it as
a random variable which leads to a
to random variable objective function
and that leads to for the challenges
you can find details in in our paper
this time control and optimization paper
and then we also looked at this we
introduced this new operator
where s is not a constant anymore but
it's a function of x
and that provides you extra flexibility
i discuss some of our work on fractional
deep neural networks
and quickly mention this application
related to chemical reacting flows
so thank you very much for your
attention